welcome to the huberman Lab podcast
where we discuss science and
science-based tools for everyday life
I'm Andrew huberman and I'm a professor
of neurobiology and Ophthalmology at
Stanford school of medicine today we are
discussing dopamine dopamine is a topic
that I've covered before on this podcast
and many people have heard of dopamine
most people know that dopamine is
involved in pleasure to some extent or
another and nowadays people are starting
to appreciate that dopamine is also
intimately involved with motivation
drive and pursuit
well today you're going to learn that
indeed dopamine is responsible for all
of those things but you are also going
to learn that dopamine is critical for
overcoming procrastination for ensuring
ongoing motivation and indeed for
ensuring confidence in fact we are going
to talk about the relationship between
dopamine and motivation and confidence
at the level of neurobiological
circuitry and we are going to cover
tools that will allow you to leverage
your dopamine in order to have a maximum
motivation to overcome sticking points
which include things like
procrastination but also by
understanding the neural circuits in the
brain and body that release and use
dopamine but more importantly by
understanding what are called dopamine
dynamics that is what gives rise to Big
peaks in dopamine or troughs in dopamine
or what's referred to as our Baseline
level of dopamine which turns out to be
our Baseline levels of motivation and
feelings of well-being by understanding
how those things relate to one another I
assure you that by the end of today's
episode you will be in a far better
position to understand why you become a
motivated why you procrastinate how to
ensure motivation on an ongoing basis
and even how to leverage effort and the
desire to become motivated as a way to
do just that to become more motivated
today's discussion is not about
psychology although I will center around
practical everyday examples and offer
many many tools that you can Implement
if you choose today's discussion is
really about pulling apart these things
that we call motivation reward pleasure
procrastination and understanding them
in terms of their dopamine Dynamics so
whether you've heard me or others talk
about dopamine before or whether or not
today is your first exposure to the
topic of dopamine today's episode is
really designed to give you the
biological and practical knowledge so
that you can leverage your dopamine
circuitry and your dopamine levels as
well as tools to adjust dopamine
circuitry and levels in order to
optimize mental health physical health
and performance before we begin I'd like
to emphasize that this podcast is
separate from my teaching and research
roles at Stanford it is however part of
my desire and effort to bring zero cost
to Consumer information about science
and science related tools to the general
public in keeping with that theme I'd
like to thank the sponsors of today's
podcast our first sponsor is Helix sleep
Helix sleep makes mattresses and pillows
that are the absolute highest quality
I've talked many times before on this
and other podcasts about the critical
role that sleep plays in allowing you to
be awake and alert and have a good
elevated mood throughout the day sleep
is just fundamental to our mental health
physical health and performance and
there's no replacing great sleep a key
thing we all need in order to get
excellent sleep is to have an ideal
sleep environment Helix mattresses are
designed for your unique sleep needs in
order to ensure that you get the best
possible night's sleep so if you go to
the Helix site and you take their very
brief two or three minute quiz it will
ask you questions such as do you sleep
on your side your back or your stomach
do you tend to run hot or cold
throughout the night and they will match
you to a mattress that's specific to
your sleep needs I match to the dusk
mattress that's the one that works for
me and since sleeping on the dusk
mattress now for well over two years
I've been sleeping better than I ever
have before so if you go to their site
you take the quiz and you figure out
what's the ideal mattress for you just
go to helixsleep.com huberman take their
two-minute sleep quiz and they'll match
you to a customized mattress and you'll
get up to 350 off any mattress order and
two free pillows again if interested you
can go to helixsleep.com huberman for up
to 350 off and two free pillows today's
episode is also brought To Us by whoop
whoop is a fitness wearable device that
tracks your daily activity and sleep but
also goes beyond that by providing
real-time feedback on how to adjust your
physical training and sleep schedule and
other activities throughout your day in
order to optimize your health I've been
working with whoop on their scientific
advisory Council to help Advance whoops
technology and mission of unlocking
Human Performance not just for athletes
but for everybody as a whoop user I've
experienced the health benefits of their
technology firsthand for instance it
tells me of course whether or not I had
a good night's sleep or a poor night
sleep by giving me a sleep score it
tells me the percentage of rapid eye
movement sleep to slow wave sleep but
whoop also tells me for instance whether
or not certain activities during my day
time such as naps or training or
training of a certain amount of
intensity how that's impacting my sleep
and vice versa if you're interested in
trying whoop you can go to join.woop.com
huberman again that join.woop.com
huberman today and you'll get your first
month free today's episode is also
brought To Us by Roka Roka makes
eyeglasses and sunglasses that are
uniquely tailored to the needs of
athletes and everyday people the company
was founded by two All-American swimmers
from Stanford and everything about Roca
eyeglasses and sunglasses were designed
with the biology the visual system in
mind I've spent a lifetime working on
the biology of the visual system and I
can tell you that your visual system has
to contend with enormous number of
challenges in order for you to be able
to see clearly Roca eyeglasses and
sunglasses are designed such that when
you go from one environment to the next
like a brightly lit environment to a
less a brightly lit environment you
don't notice that transition you always
see with perfect clarity another
terrific thing about Roka eyeglasses and
sunglasses is that many of the
performance glasses out there that are
designed for sport make people look like
cyborgs which if you want that they do
have those options the cyborg options as
I call them but they also have many
options where the aesthetic is more of
the sort that you would wear to dinner
or to work or anywhere that you happen
to be if you'd like to try Roca
eyeglasses or sunglasses go to Roka
that's Roka Dot com and enter the code
huberman to save 20 off your first order
again that's Roca roka.com and enter the
code huberman at checkout the huberman
Lab podcast is now partnered with
momentous supplements to find the
supplements we discussed on the huberman
Lab podcast you can go to live momentous
spelled ous live momentous.com huberman
and I should just mention that the
library of those supplements is
constantly expanding again that's
livmomentis.com huberman okay let's talk
about dopamine what is dopamine dopamine
is what's called a neuromodulator which
simply refers to the fact that it's a
chemical that modulates or changes the
electrical activity of other cells and
the cells I'm referring to are neurons
neurons are just nerve cells so you have
a brain and a spinal cord and the
neurons in your brain and spinal cord
connect to one another and they connect
to different areas of the body including
basically every organ of your body and
every organ of your body communicates
back to your brain and spinal cord
through Direct act or indirect Pathways
for instance you have neurons in your
gut that sense what sorts of nutrients
you've eaten or drank and then send
neural signals electrical signals up to
the brain and indeed that whole process
happens to be modulated by dopamine
dopamine as a neuromodulator has the
basic property of either ramping up
increasing or decreasing the activity of
other neurons and that's done by
adjusting things like electrical
potentials and things of that sort that
we really won't go into this episode but
that I promise to get into in detail in
a future episode if you're interested in
the biochemistry and biophysics of
neurons and things of that sort
so we have this neuromodulator dopamine
and we know that that neuromodulator can
increase or decrease the activity of
other neurons
so then we have to ask ourselves where
is dopamine released in the brain and
body and what specific types of neurons
is it impacting in other words what
specific types of functions does
dopamine have so there are basically
five circuits within the brain that use
dopamine as the primary neuromodulator
and those five circuits engage different
but related functions so I'm going to go
through them one by one relatively
quickly giving you a little bit of
nomenclature and some sense of what each
of those circuits looks like and what it
does the first circuit is the so-called
Nigro striatal pathway so in the back of
the brain there's an area called
substantia so named because the
neurons that are actually very dark they
actually contain pigment you'd be able
to see this if I were to slice up a
brain you'd see two dark regions in the
back that substantia Niagara substantia
Niagara contains neurons that are chock
a block full of dopamine but they
release that dopamine in a brain
structure called the striatum the
striatum is involved in movement both
the initiation of movements and the
suppression of movements in so-called go
action and no go suppress action
pathways topic for a future podcast the
second brain circuit that uses and
leverages dopamine to a great extent is
the so-called mesolimbic pathway now
you'll also in a moment hear about the
mesocortical pathway so today I'm going
to talk about these somewhat
interchangeably at times but where it's
important for me to differentiate
between them I will do that both of
these Pathways initiate from a set of
neurons in the so-called ventral
tegmental area or VTA I will use that
acronym VTA the VTA functions in close
partnership with a different brain
structure called the nucleus accumbens
or n a i don't think I'll call it n a
today I'll talk about VTA ventral
tegmental area and I'll talk about
nucleus accumbens for sake of today's
discussion you can lump those together
if you want
neurons in those areas project a bunch
of different places but in the
mesolimbic pathway those neurons are
projecting to areas of the brain like
the hypothalamus which sits right above
the roof of your mouth and is
responsible for a lot of basic functions
things like maintaining your body
temperature for libido in the pursuit of
sex for Hunger for the generation of
signals to the pituitary gland that
cause the release of
hormones and other things into the
bloodstream so the connections which I
sometimes refer to as projections from
the neurons in the VTA and nucleus
accumbens to the hypothalamus are
basically using dopamine to modulate the
output of a lot of different things that
happen in this hypothalamus that
controls a lot of we could call them
primitive functions but they're really
basic functions for survival now the
other pathway out of the VTA and nucleus
accumbens is to the cortex that's why
it's called mesocortical pathway so this
is a very different pathway out of the
VTA and nucleus accumbens than the one I
just described a moment ago the pathway
I'm talking about now the mesocortical
pathway projects to the prefrontal
cortex which is a structure that many of
you have perhaps heard of but even if
you haven't it's important to know this
is an area that resides right behind
your forehead
and that in humans compared to other
species is greatly expanded in terms of
its size and complexity of function so
it's involved in everything from
planning and executing of action to
making good or bad decisions depending
on context in fact one of the primary
functions of prefrontal Cortex is to
really understand context whether or not
for instance you are alone in your room
where certain behaviors are appropriate
whether or not you are at work where
other behaviors are appropriate
understanding what the context is and
therefore what sorts of actions need to
be generated and suppressed in fact a
guest on the huberman Lab podcast and
this is a guess whose episode hasn't
aired yet described this beautifully
he's a neurosurgeon and he said the way
to think about the prefrontal cortex is
it's basically an area of the brain that
says
or no not now to other brain regions in
order to suppress action we know this
because people that have damage to the
prefrontal cortex
often can't suppress their impulses okay
so the pathway from VTA and nucleus
accumbens to the prefrontal cortex is
absolutely critical for today's
discussion because we are largely going
to be discussing motivation Drive
Pursuit procrastination and all sorts of
things that have to do with our feelings
about context whether or not we want to
do something or not whether or not we
feel we should or we shouldn't whether
or not we feel we failed the last time
or there's a high probability of success
the next time prefrontal cortex does
many many things but when thinking about
dopamine's role in the prefrontal cortex
that is when thinking about this
mesocortical pathway we really want to
think about how dopamine is activating
or changing our propensity to do certain
things and get us into action or prevent
us from doing certain things and prevent
action so basically you can think about
the mesocortical pathway as a circuit
that really governs all of the major
choices that you're going to make in
life about what to do and what not to do
toward your goals and away from the
things that you want to avoid now the
fourth dopamine pathway in the brain is
the so-called tubero infundibular
pathway and this is not one we're going
to focus on too much today this is a
pathway that relates to connections
between the brain and your pituitary
gland your pituitary gland being that
gland that's as I mentioned a moment ago
is also receiving input from the
hypothalamus and is releasing a bunch of
hormones into your bloodstream things
like luteinizing hormone follicle
stimulating hormone things like
melanocortin hormone these are hormones
that are impacting everything from the
function of the ovary and females to the
function of the testes and males it's
governing things like cortisol release
under stress thyroid hormone meaning
it's regulating thyroid hormone release
and on and on dopamine has a very
powerful impact on the output of the
pituitary so again that's probably a
topic for a future episode but it's
important in reviewing the different
brain circuits that use dopamine as a
neuromodulator that I mentioned that one
then there's a fifth one and this fifth
one is not often discussed and again
won't be the main topic of today's
discussion but for thoroughness and for
clarity it's important that we mention
it this is the circuit within your
retina that is the pie crust-like lining
of neural tissue on the back of your eye
because remember your eye is actually
part of your brain that got extruded
from your brain during development you
know those two eyes that you see in the
mirror and that you see in other people
are actually two pieces of central
nervous system and within the retina
which is the neural portion of the eye
within the neural retina
dopamine is responsible for adapting to
different light conditions so that you
can see clearly both in the evening and
when it gets darker you can still see a
bit and in the morning when it's very
bright you don't really have to make
adjustments to your visual system in
order to see clearly your visual system
does it for you and one of the ways that
it does that is through the
neuromodulator dopamine so today we are
not going to discuss the retinal
dopamine Pathways or the
tuberinfrendibular dopamine Pathways and
we won't really talk so much about the
Nigro striatal pathway I'll say one more
thing about it and then I'll leave it
alone we are going to talk about the
mesocortical pathway and we might touch
on the mesolimic pathway a little bit as
well so today we're mostly going to talk
about mesocortical circuitry and
function and dopamine within the
mesocortical circuit and the reason that
we're doing that is that today's
discussion is really about motivation
procrastination goal setting and pursuit
it's very important to understand that
neither dopamine nor the mesocortical
circuit cares about any specific goal or
Pursuit this is a circuit that uses
dopamine in order to pursue anything
now of course some people have a greater
propensity to pursue things like work or
goals and Athletics or relationships or
a combination of those other people
unfortunately have a greater propensity
to pursue things like drugs of abuse
what are drugs of abuse drugs of abuse
tend to be drugs that increase levels of
dopamine to the extent that other types
of Pursuits in life that are adaptive
for us like work relationship School Etc
become Irrelevant in fact the definition
of addiction that I use and that I
believe really matches the neurobiology
very well is that addiction is a
progressive narrowing of the things that
bring us pleasure healthy functioning of
the mesocortical pathway however allows
us to toggle or switch back and forth
between different types of Pursuits of
all the sorts that I've mentioned
earlier so if we can understand how that
means the cortical pathway works just a
little bit in particular when dopamine
is released and when it's not released
what dopamine does when it's released to
our sense of motivation and drive
and if we can understand a little bit
about how our recent dopamine history
that is whether or not there is dopamine
in our system already
dictates whether or not we are going to
feel motivated in the next 5 10 15
minutes hours days and weeks that is all
very easy to understand I promise I'll
explain it to you in a simple way but I
want you to get a circuit into your mind
I want you to Envision that there are
these neurons little nerve cells in the
VTA and nucleus accumbens those neurons
make dopamine they send their
projections that we call axons which are
like little wires and they can release
dopamine into the prefrontal cortex and
now you already know because you learned
it a few minutes ago that the prefrontal
cortex then can ensure that certain
behaviors take place and other behaviors
do not take place that or quieting that
we talked about earlier
with that in mind let's now take a look
at how dopamine is released and let's
keep two things in mind there are peaks
in dopamine that is dopamine is released
into the frontal cortex where it has
these effects of activating or
suppressing action
and we can think of those as peaks in
dopamine so if I call it a spike that
means an increase and then a decrease if
I call it a peak it's an increase and
then a decrease there can also be
troughs in dopamine what do I mean by
that well we have Peaks and dopamine and
that Peak and dopamine can rise up and
then go back to what we call baseline or
there can be a trough it can go below
Baseline so the two key things to
understand about dopamine is that we
have dopamine Peaks that are triggered
by certain behaviors certain compounds
drugs or substances food
Etc and that we have a dopamine Baseline
our dopamine Baseline is our reservoir
of dopamine it's how full or empty our
dopamine pool is and that dopamine pool
is the pool of dopamine that we use in
order to create those dopamine Peaks and
when those Peaks come down sometimes
they go back to Baseline and sometimes
they go to lower the base slime which we
call the trough
if any of this seems confusing I want
you just to imagine a wave pool this is
an analogy that was given to me by one
of our podcast guests which is Dr Kyle
Gillette who's an obesity specialist and
works on a number of things related to
endocrine hormone function including
testosterone estrogen in both men and
women you want to check out his episodes
on Hormone Health
now they're fascinating and actionable
he's a tremendous wealth of knowledge
and he has this analogy for how dopamine
Works in our brain and body and that
analogy is this notion of a wave pool if
you've ever seen a wave pool it's
basically a concrete pool and there are
waves within it okay duh those waves can
be of different heights so they can be
little Ripples and we can think of those
as little mini Peaks or they can be big
waves they can be really big crashing
waves
if the height of those waves and the
frequency of those waves is very very
large so some of that water which here
I'm using as an analogy to dopamine can
slosh out of the wave pool and the
Baseline drops However if those Peaks
are small enough
or they are seldom enough
well then the Baseline that is the water
level in that pool stays more or less
constant I think this is an excellent
analogy for how dopamine works in the
mesocortical pathway as it relates to
motivation and pursuit and all those
sorts of things because we really need
to think about how the Peaks and the
Baseline relate to one another
and this is very important the Peaks on
the Baseline are not independent of one
another they relate to one another so
now you have in your mind a wave pool
and just understand that if you get a
great big huge wave maybe one of them it
will crash out and some of that water
will Splash out the Baseline will go
down a little bit but if you get big
peak after big peak after big peak
pretty soon you're going to empty that
pool whereas if you have smaller waves
or less frequent big waves well then the
Baseline will stay relatively constant
so let's think about dopamine Peaks and
bass lines and let's remember that for
every Peak there's a trough what do I
mean by that well when you have a wave
you also have the bottom of the wave
when you have a mountain you have the
bottom of the mountain
when we think about dopamine Peaks and
dopamine baselines we have to include
that trough because that trough that is
the level of dopamine below Baseline
really dictates whether or not you are
going to feel motivated to pursue
something or not so I'm going to give
you a visual in your mind the visual in
your mind is an increase in dopamine
that's triggered by your desire for
something and really could be your
desire for anything if you're hungry and
you're thinking about I really want a
sandwich I really want to let's think
what sandwich would I want right now a
really nice roast beef sandwich on
sourdough with a slice of Swiss Tomatoes
slice of pickle here I'm describing the
sandwich that I would want so if you're
hungry and you're thinking about that
dopamine starts Rising this is crucially
important to understand dopamine is not
just released when we get the reward
when we get the thing that we're
pursuing dopamine is released in
anticipation of what we want
that increase in dopamine
is by no happenstance no mistake
relates also to our propensity and
desire to move remember earlier I told
you there's a separate Circuit of
dopamine that triggers movement and that
when it's depleted is causing things
like deficits and movement related to
Parkinson's or other movement disorders
well that's not pure coincidence that's
because desire and the need to move in
order to pursue and reach goals are one
in the same process
so if I desire a sandwich or I desire a
cup of coffee or I desire some water
when I'm thirsty there's an increase in
dopamine that we could call a little
mini Peak and dopamine
but then here's the key thing very soon
after I realized my desire for something
that Peak that was caused by the desire
comes down and drops below Baseline
below the level of dopamine that it was
prior to even thinking about the
sandwich or the coffee or the glass of
water
and it's that drop below Baseline that
triggers my desire to go out and find
that sandwich that coffee that water or
that blank insert whatever it is that
you happen to desire action or substance
of any kind or person Etc
so that drop below Baseline is
fundamental to the whole process and
that drop below Baseline was triggered
by the preceding Peak so let's say that
I desire a sandwich there's an increase
in dopamine then very quickly it comes
down below Baseline just a little bit
now I'm in pursuit of the sandwich I'm
looking for where I can get that
sandwich I can order it perhaps to be
delivered I can go out and find it
now is the stage in which I have to
think about what are the different
stimuli that is the things in my
environment that signal whether or not
I'm likely to get that sandwich or not
okay so for instance if I were to go to
my phone and order food on an app or
walk down the street and see the sign
for a deli that's a cue that I'm likely
to relieve that drop in dopamine and get
not just back to Baseline but then I'll
get a peak in dopamine and indeed that's
what happens if I find that Deli I go
into the deli they're open they're
making the sandwich that I want they
make my sandwich and great I get that
sandwich and that sandwich will have
some degree of inherent reward to it
some degree of my liking it or not
liking it so let's say I like it it's
not the best sandwich I've ever had but
all I'm doing is comparing my desire for
that sandwich to the sandwich that I
actually got and ate and chances are
it's going to relieve that craving
meaning it will take that dopamine that
had fallen below Baseline up up back to
Baseline and if I like the sandwich it's
going to indeed increase that dopamine
again to another Peak
now if I love the sandwich like it's the
most delicious thing that I've ever
tasted in my entire life well then I'll
get a big peak in dopamine when I
consume that reward however chances are
that sandwiches more or less as I expect
it to be which is pretty good I'll eat
it and I'm fine what do I mean by fine
well there's a concept called reward
prediction error reward prediction error
says that the dopamine that it is
experienced that is that's released from
the VTA and nucleus accumbens
is going to be of a certain value and
that value is going to be compared to
the desire and expectation of what I
thought I was going to get so if you
take what you actually got minus what
you expected that's reward prediction
error so if the sandwich is basically
what I expected to get fine dopamine
comes down basically to a baseline level
that's pretty standard for me and is
basically the Baseline level I had
before I ever thought about the sandwich
at all
if the sandwich completely surprises me
and is completely amazing just an
amazing sandwich well then the level of
dopamine that I experience when I
consume that sandwich is going to be
even greater and it's going to be that
minus what I expected so there it's a
bigger reward prediction error in the
direction of higher Peak by consuming
the sandwich
and then of course there's the other
possibility which is the deli's closed
or the sandwich they make me is lousy or
doesn't taste good or something happened
in the consuming of that sandwich that
just makes a bad experience in which
case if we take that reward experienced
minus reward predicted from the initial
craving well then it's going to be less
than what I expected and therefore the
Baseline drops below where it was prior
to even Desiring the sandwich okay so
all of this might seem a little bit
complicated but it's all very simple
desire for things increases dopamine
but then our level of dopamine drops
below Baseline and it's that drop below
Baseline that triggers the motivation to
bring that dopamine level back up by
going and pursuing the thing that you
wanted in the first place now of course
as this is happening you're not
conscious of your dopamine levels you
experience this as context-dependent
craving and pursuit because remember the
prefrontal cortex is involved in context
setting and craving and pursuit because
it relates to action and movement which
is one of the general features of the
dopamine system so you can start to see
how this is a beautifully designed
system and you can also see how it's a
perfect system for desire and pursuit of
anything not just sandwiches as I'm
giving you in this somewhat trivial but
every day and therefore applicable
example so just by understanding reward
prediction error and especially by
understanding that a craving triggers a
peak in dopamine that makes you
motivated but then drops your level of
dopamine below Baseline which makes you
even more motivated
you are already halfway through the
conceptual aspect of today's podcast
because if you can understand that you
will understand why for instance when
you initially want something or you
think you want something
it puts you into motion but then pretty
quickly you're starting to feel the pain
of not having that and that is also
contributing to your desire to pursue
that thing this is a subtle effect but
if you watch for it you'll start to see
it or experience it within yourself your
craving for things is not just about
craving for those things per se it's
also a desire to relieve the pain of not
having those things and if you can
internalize that and start to develop an
awareness around it you will be in an
amazing position to leverage all sorts
of aspects of the dopamine system in
order to increase your motivation
especially when things get really hard
or when you have the propensity to
procrastinate which is something that
we'll get into a little bit later in the
podcast I'd like to take a quick break
and acknowledge one of our sponsors
athletic greens athletic greens now
called ag1 is a vitamin mineral
probiotic drink that covers all of your
foundational nutritional needs I've been
taking athletic green since 2012. so I'm
delighted that they're sponsoring the
podcast the reason I started taking
athletic greens and the reason I still
take athletic greens once are usually
twice a day is that it gets to be the
probiotics that I need for gut health
our gut is very important it's populated
by gut microbiota that communicate with
the brain the immune system and
basically all the biological systems of
our body to strongly impact our
immediate and long-term health
and those probiotics and athletic greens
are optimal and vital for microbiotic
health in addition athletic greens
contains a number of adaptogens vitamins
and minerals that make sure that all of
my foundational nutritional needs are
met and it tastes great if you'd like to
try athletic greens you can go to
athleticgreens.com huberman and they'll
give you five free travel packs that
make it really easy to mix up athletic
greens while you're on the road in the
car on the plane Etc and they'll give
you a year's supply of vitamin d3k2
again that's athleticgreens.com huberman
to get the five free travel packs and
the year supply of vitamin D3 K2 now I'd
like to talk about the Dynamics of
dopamine release with a little bit more
detail and this is something I've never
covered on any social media post or on
any podcast either this one or as a
guest on other podcasts because on the
face of it it might seem a little too
detailed like why is he telling me all
this isn't it just enough to know that
there are Peaks and troughs and bass
lines and dopamine well it turns out
that if you can understand what that
Peak and trough are really about in
other words what's really happening when
we zoom in on that Peak and trough
you'll be in an amazing position to
overcome procrastination and essentially
pursue any goals in an ongoing basis so
I'm very excited to share this
information with you because I do think
that it has tremendous actionable power
what I'm about to describe relates to a
number of different findings that have
been made mostly over the last five to
ten years although to be quite direct
mostly within the last five years and it
has to do with the fact that the peak
and trough and Baseline that I talked
about a moment ago that are associated
with craving
they look like a peak followed by a
trough followed by a return to Baseline
and maybe another Peak if you get the
reward or a drop below Baseline if you
don't or you don't like what you got
but if we were to zoom in on that Peak
and the reward in other words really
zoom in on the whole process and start
thinking about the circuitry that is the
neurons in VTA and nucleus accumbens and
how it relates to the frontal cortex in
a bit more detail what we discover is
nothing short of amazing
what we discover is that whenever we're
pursuing something we are always looking
for cues as to whether or not we are on
the right path
to achieve that thing and we are also
setting a mindset or a context within
our brains
as to whether or not we are confident or
pessimistic as to whether or not we're
going to achieve that thing now this is
vitally important for anyone out there
who finds it hard to get motivated and
stay motivated it's also vitally
important for anyone who's
psychologically minded in any way you
don't have to be a psychologist but
psychologically minded in any way and
wonders why is it that some people are
just so motivated and other people have
such trouble with motivation why is it
that some people require perfect
conditions in order to achieve things
and other people just seem to manage to
pursue things no matter what it also
relates to the fact that some of us are
very good at achieving our goals in one
context and not so much in another so
here's what you need to understand
I'll stay with the example of the roast
beef sandwich just because we already
have that in mind but you can replace
roast beef sandwich with essentially any
goal
the cue that we're going to likely
get what we want so for instance the
sign that there's a deli on the corner
or that I open my phone and that there's
an app
that represents a restaurant that sells
the particular sandwich that I like that
cue as I mentioned before increases
dopamine you see that like oh okay and
subconsciously there's already a signal
that's initiated by that dopamine that
I'm on the right path
then as I mentioned dopamine drops below
Baseline that's further contributing to
my desire to go pursue that sandwich
either with my thumbs on my phone
through the app or with my feet and
walking to the deli standing in line and
so forth
then as I mentioned before there is a
peak in dopamine of varying height
depending on how satisfying I find the
reward to be
when I actually get that sandwich get
that goal
now keep in mind there is some time
delay between the queue
the app the deli
Etc and when I get my sandwich
that Gap is going to be different for
different things so in pursuing uh you
know four-year degree it's going to be
four years if the diploma is your goal
if if it's an exam you're studying for
it might be a week long
and there will be many other signals in
between that initial cue that hey the
the reward likely lies down this path in
this textbook in um on you know this
dating app or at that Deli there are
many other cues
those cues come in subconsciously and
involve everything from how long the
line is at the deli to you know whether
or not you're you know seeing the types
of people on a dating app that you'd
like to see whether or not they're
responding to you whether or not
someone's texting you back or not
all of those cues are integrated and
adjusting your Baseline level of
dopamine all the time
as you go to pursue that goal
so what the dopamine system does is it
doesn't just compare the height of the
Peak at the beginning right the I desire
that to the reward that you got we
talked about reward prediction error
that's the that's the
kind of first grade version of reward
prediction error it's also taking into
account all the things that happen in
between and all of that is serving as a
cue for the eventual reward and all of
that is funneling into what we call
reward prediction error
in other words the dopamine system is
very good at subconsciously parsing what
are the things that happen between
wanting and getting
and that's part of the learning that
dopamine achieves and indeed there are
specialized circuits from the VTA and
nucleus accumbens that are involved in
just the learning of how we achieve or
don't achieve specific types of rewards
that we desire so this is called reward
contingent learning because it's
learning the contingencies of what led
up to a reward or what didn't lead up to
a reward
at the same time end in parallel there's
an ongoing release of dopamine in the
background and that ongoing release of
dopamine that has nothing to do with
learning is really just sort of a
propeller that's driving us in the
direction of whatever it is that we're
trying to pursue
so I realize for some of you this might
seem like unnecessary or perhaps even an
overwhelming amount of detail
but it's actually quite simple
your brain is trying to figure out what
happened prior to getting or not getting
a reward and it's comparing what you
wanted compared to what you got
at the same time the dopamine system
initiates a motivation signal that takes
you through that entire round of pursuit
and those three things there's the
stimulus the desire the I want that
that's the first thing that leads to
that Peak the peak drops a little bit
below Baseline and it triggers
motivation the motivation is the second
thing
the motivation is dopamine release also
but from a separate set of neurons
within this circuit driving you forward
and the entire time that it's driving
you forward
it's paying attention to what's there
along the way even if you don't realize
it consciously and then there's the
reward itself or the lack of reward
itself so those three components
the learning contingency which has to do
with the stimulus and the reward
and everything that happens in between
and the propeller nature of dopamine as
I'm referring to it those all combine
into a total learning so that after you
get the sandwich or after you finish the
exam or after you go out on a date or
after you do anything that you desire to
do
that system that originates in the VTA
and nucleus accumbens and goes up to
your cortex it learned it learned many
things it learned the contingency
between stimulus and desire motivation
and whether or not you succeeded or not
it's basically a scoreboard for how you
did given what just happened
so actually it's all very simple in fact
if you can understand even just half of
what I just said
you are now in a far better position to
understand everything from addiction to
motivation to procrastination and it
will make sense of all the tools that
I'm going to talk about next which will
allow you to overcome procrastination
points to overcome deficits in
motivation and indeed to reset your
motivation in an ongoing way so that you
can reach your goals okay so let's take
everything that I just told you and set
it aside it's still important but let's
just say this you don't have to think
about any of those details or names or
anything
let's just think about addiction
because in biology and in Psychology
frankly it really often pays to think
about the extremes first and then work
our way towards more typical
circumstances and with that said
addiction unfortunately is very common
nowadays I just heard a statistic in
fact that
there is an 8080 percent increase in
alcohol use disorder among women in the
last 30 years I talked a little bit
about this in the episode that I did
about alcohol and health
again I want to be very clear I'm not
somebody that is completely against
alcohol for adults provided they're not
alcoholics
turns out two drinks a week probably
fine health-wise zero would be better if
we're honest zero is better than any
alcohol but two drinks a week is
probably fine past two drinks you start
running into problems and yet many many
people out there male and female alike
suffer from alcohol use disorder also
called alcoholism
the same is also true for things like
methamphetamine or cocaine or other
types of substance addictions
and the same is also true for a lot of
Behavioral or what are sometimes called
process addictions things like sex
addiction or video game addiction or any
type of behavior that frankly is
leveraging the dopamine system but that
engages this Progressive narrowing of
the things that bring someone pleasure
such that nothing else is really Salient
nothing else is really pulling them in
in the way that they're video games or
sex or pornography or alcohol
pick your substance or
you know behavior that you see out there
or hopefully not but that you might
suffer from an addiction too so what's
happening in addiction
well addiction involves dopamine among
other things often the opioid system Etc
but if we were to think about what's the
stimulus in an addiction and what's the
peak in dopamine and then what happens
after that Peak It all becomes very
clear as to why addiction happens and
why it's so pernicious
so for instance let's take cocaine
cocaine causes dramatic increases in
dopamine very very fast so if somebody
craves cocaine
what are they craving they're craving
that dopamine Peak they're craving the
increased level of alertness they're
craving a number of things associated
with the feeling of being under the
influence of the drug but the stimulus
for it simply becomes that line of
cocaine or in the case of crack that
crack rock that they're going to smoke
and God forbid they're mainlining it you
know they're shooting into a vein what
happens is they snort smoke or inject
cocaine and dopamine levels almost
immediately
go up up up up up up to a very high peak
okay so the the time gap between the
stimulus and the dopamine is very very
short
so short in fact that there's really no
other contingencies in between that the
mesocortical system has to learn in fact
what is the system quote unquote learn
it learns
cocaine equals massive amounts of
dopamine equals feeling euphoric and
energetic Etc
and in doing that
it reinforces the whole circuit so that
that short we can even say hyper short
contingency is really what the system
wants
so much so that longer contingencies of
say putting in the hard work of you know
generating a fitness program or a
professional program for yourself or a
education program which takes not just
many days but many weeks and years well
none of that is going to lead to peace
in dopamine that are as high as the
Pekin dopamine associated with cocaine
so that tells us something critical
it is both the duration between desire
end effect and when I say effect I mean
the rewarding properties of dopamine
that are experienced that's important so
very short gaps
teach the system to expect and want
short gaps
makes it very hard to pursue things that
take longer
so when we say it's the short or in this
case hyper short distance or time
between the stimulus and the dopamine
what we're really talking about if we
were to plot this out on a on a board or
on a piece of paper is the steepness of
the rise of that Peak it's very very
steep the peak in dopamine is coming up
very fast after the desire
and in addition to that and this is very
important the higher the peak in
dopamine and the faster the rise to that
Peak the further below Baseline the
dopamine drops after the drug wears off
okay so in the case of cocaine it's a
very fast and very large rise in
dopamine followed by a steep drop
and very deep trough in dopamine below
Baseline
you say okay so there's pleasure then
there's lack of pleasure ah but it's
worse than that because it's not just
lack of pleasure if you recall what we
talked about a little bit earlier that
drop below Baseline triggers
the desire and the pursuit for what for
more
and so this sets in motion a vicious
Loop where people start pursuing peaks
in dopamine that can come very fast
without much effort
and that's one of the ways in which
addictions start to take hold
there's a simple way to think about this
and to remember if you want to avoid
this whole thing I mean the first one is
obvious don't do cocaine don't try it
don't use it certainly don't get
addicted to it
those are all sort of one in the same
frankly I don't know many people that
despite
opinions to the contrary that use
cocaine recreationally that don't at
some point run into either a financial
psychological physical or some other
problem the other thing that's
absolutely critical to keep in mind and
this was discussed in my colleague Dr
Anna lemke's book dopamine nation and on
this podcast excellent book by the way I
highly recommend it if you haven't read
it already it's a fascinating
exploration into dopamine as it relates
to addiction not just drug addiction but
other types of addiction again the name
of that book is dopamine Nation we'll
provide a link to it in the show note
captions
the other thing that happens after those
big fast increases in dopamine caused by
things like cocaine is
afterwards when it quickly drops below
Baseline
it takes a much longer time to get back
to the original Baseline than it did
prior to using the drug
and worse still is that the peaks in
dopamine that are created from more
consumption of cocaine leads to
progressively lower Peaks
and deeper troughs below Baseline so the
whole system is Shifting away from
pleasure and more to pain and the desire
for pursuit of the drug
now
this is a terrible situation and it's a
terrible situation that's not just
unique to cocaine in fact if we were to
look at the averages and again these are
averages of the height of the peaks in
dopamine that are created by different
substances and the rates at which those
Peaks take place because remember the
time to Peak is just as important as how
high that Peak goes
we see some pretty interesting numbers
so for instance and again these are
averages based on neuroimaging combined
with
um what are called pet scans positron
emission tomography combined with blood
draws and a number of other data from
both animal and human studies
you find is that at Baseline just kind
of on a background of no drug taking of
any kind the neurons in the Venture
pigmental nucleus accumbens area are
firing at a rate of about three to four
per second releasing dopamine so that's
your Baseline of dopamine release your
your forebrain is always seeing a little
bit of dopamine from from that system
if you were then to anticipate food and
you're relatively hungry
that would double okay so this probably
happened when you decide to eat lunch
today if you were hungry prior to eating
lunch
it doubles in the anticipation of the
food and then depending on how much you
enjoyed that food it might triple or
quadruple it might be lower than it was
during the anticipation as we talked
about before
so there's an approximate doubling under
conditions of Desiring and consuming
food
let's take nicotine as the next example
for people that use nicotine either
smoking vaping snuffing or dipping
all routes of nicotine Administration
that I covered in our episode about
nicotine
there's about a 150 percent increase in
the rate of dopamine neuron firing
cocaine is going to increase the rate of
dopamine output into the prefrontal
cortex by about a thousand percent okay
so what you're really talking about here
is a tenfold increase
in the amount of of dopamine that's
released into the prefrontal cortex as
measured by the rates of firing of these
dopamine neurons
methamphetamine is going to be anywhere
from a thousand percent anywhere up to
ten thousand percent it really varies
depending on the potency of the drug and
a few other factors and here's where
perhaps it gets a little more
interesting some of you are probably
wondering about caffeine or about sex or
about video games now they're the
numbers vary tremendously and it's
really important to understand that
across the board not just for caffeine
sex video games but also for nicotine
alcohol and other substances and what we
call motivated behaviors some of which
are part of a healthy life like eating
and reproduction you know provided it's
you know age-appropriate context
appropriate you know species appropriate
consensual well then we consider it
adaptive if it's not well then
considered maladaptive
some people will sit down to play a
video game they really like video games
and as they're sitting down they will
experience a five-fold increase in the
rate of dopamine output from their
nucleus accumbens for other people it's
going to be a tenfold increase for other
people like me who don't like video
games very much I don't have anything
against them I don't dislike them but it
doesn't do much for me
it might not cause any increase
whatsoever it might even cause a
decrease in dopamine so there's a lot of
individual variability for sex it turns
out to be a range so the typical range
that's cited in the literature is
anywhere from a four to five-fold
increase in the rate of dopamine neuron
firing however there are certain
individuals for which that number is
doubled caffeine is a little bit of a
special circumstance because caffeine
has the property of not just causing the
release of dopamine but increasing the
amount of dopamine receptors over time
and there aren't a lot of excellent
measurements of the amount of dopamine
released as a function of caffeine
intake in different populations of
humans it's mostly animal studies but
what we think based on the Gestalt based
on the overall picture of the literature
is that it's an approximate doubling of
the dopamine signaling that's coming out
of the VTA nucleus accumens to
prefrontal Cortex when we anticipate and
when we drink our coffee
again I really want to be clear that for
all of these things these are relative
levels and they are distribution so if
we were to plot them out on paper you
would see that these are not bar graphs
these are overlapping curves to some
extent so some people are going to
achieve more dopamine release or less
dopamine release from one Behavior or
substance however it's very clear that
cocaine methamphetamine
even heroin for that matter are way out
on the right hand side of the curve
causing enormous increases in dopamine
very quickly and the other things that
we described have again a distribution
that is more leftward shifted on this
imaginary plot that I'm creating
it's a lot of individual variability
however it's fascinating that dopamine
is the single molecule that's causing
the craving and pursuit and experience
of all of these substances and behaviors
and the learning of all of that craving
Pursuit and actual experience is what
predicts whether or not we will
re-engage reuse that substance or not
re-engage in a behavior or not and how
frequently we will do that so that's
addiction but if you understand how the
height of those peaks in dopamine and
the rate to reach those Peaks and the
troughs that result and how long the
troughs take to get back to Baseline if
you understand or a little or all of
that
you're really in a terrific position to
understand how to Leverage The dopamine
system for the pursuit of healthy goals
and behaviors I should mention one thing
about recovery from addiction which is
that the reset of all that dopamine
circuitry from unhealthy to healthy
often involves depending on the
addiction 30 days of complete abstinence
that 30 days of complete abstinence
inevitably involves a lot of pain and
discomfort and craving anxiety insomnia
Etc that relates to the big trough in
dopamine that inevitably occurs now of
course there are some addictions such as
severe alcohol addiction and in some
cases opiate addiction that immediate
and sustained abstinence cannot be used
as the tool somebody really needs to
work with an addiction specialist and
sometimes there needs to be a tapering
off of the substance for other
addictions it can be quote unquote cold
turkey and then of course there are
other addictions particularly food and
sex but sometimes even things like video
games for which the desired outcome is
not necessarily to eliminate the
behavior completely but to set some
constraints around the behavior so that
it's not occurring to the exclusion of
other pleasureful things in life and
adaptive things in life and for that
there is the requirement for what are
called binding behaviors we'll get back
to binding behaviors later but binding
behaviors or behaviors in which people
bind their behavior
around a particular substance use or
around a particular behavioral addiction
like sex Video Games Etc in space and or
time in space meaning they might only
engage in those particular behaviors in
certain places and certain times when
it's context appropriate there are
numerous examples of binding behaviors
in space and time it all has to do with
clamping or directing when the
engagement with the dopamine releasing
behavior is going to occur so what's
happening when people decide to go cold
turkey or they use these binding
behaviors well what's happening is that
people are engaging the specific
circuitry within the prefrontal cortex
that as I mentioned at the beginning of
the episode are important for context
setting so in the cases of binding
behaviors the prefrontal cortex is
essentially getting trained up to
understand that okay certain things like
food or perhaps sex or perhaps video
games
they're okay if they are done or
consumed in
appropriate amounts or in particular
context that requires the context
setting goal directed behavior that the
prefrontal cortex is responsible okay so
for the last 10 or 15 minutes we've been
talking a lot about addiction and
actually this is not an episode about
addiction however if you understand a
little bit about the dopamine Dynamics
in an addiction you can leverage that
knowledge towards healthy adaptive goal
Pursuit and achieving your goals so
let's think about that in the context of
what generates dopamine Peaks what
generates desire to pursue goals what
causes our readout of whether or not we
achieved a goal or not in other words
what allows us to learn how to pursue
goals of different kinds not just get
good at achieving one kind of goal but
really understand and get really really
good at setting goals and pursuing goals
of different kinds that are adaptive in
different areas of life because we all
are going to have to pursue goals in
school work relationships Fitness mental
health and on and on in order to be our
best selves that's clear
well all of that is possible using the
same basic set of dopamine circuits and
the same basic dynamics of dopamine so
for instance if we are going to feel
motivated at all that is if we are going
to wake up in the morning or have any
period of time during our day in which
we feel like we are capable of pursuing
goals
we are going to have to have a healthy
level of Baseline dopamine in other
words we are going to have to have
enough dopamine in the wave pool enough
water in the wave pool that is
before we can generate any waves or
peaks in dopamine let alone troughs and
the rest so how do we achieve a healthy
Baseline level of dopamine well there we
can really look to some foundational
practices practices that perhaps you've
heard about on this podcast before and
that to some of you might seem a little
mundane although some of them are a bit
more sophisticated maybe even esoteric
the good news is that we can all control
these things and they don't require
purchasing anything but they do require
some degree of regular upkeep and effort
those things include what I call the
very Basics now the very Basics put in
the context of today's discussion are
the things that put water in the wave
pool those are going to be getting
sufficient amounts of quality sleep each
night something that we've done several
episodes on and then have online
toolkits for us you can see the master
your sleep episode the perfect your
sleep episode the light and health
episode if you want to skip all that and
just get right to the tools we have a
sleep tool kit or it's actually called
the toolkit for sleep that you can
access at hubermanlab.com completely
zero cost you just go there and download
that toolkit getting sufficient sleep
each night literally restores your
dopamine reserves it allows dopamine to
be present and for you to have a level
of Baseline dopamine that will allow you
to even consider your goals in any kind
of meaningful or reasonable way
second there are practices that are
supported by the scientific literature
to increase your Baseline level of
dopamine that are independent of sleep
but are similar to sleep and I like to
refer to these as non-sleep deep rest
this is not meditation there's actually
very little evidence that meditation of
the traditional kind of you know sitting
eyes closed third eye sent focusing on
your third eye center which is this area
behind your forehead there is very
little evidence that that increases
levels of dopamine there is a place for
meditation in the context of today's
discussion but I'll repeat
meditation itself is a focusing exercise
it is not known to increase dopamine
however non-sleep deep breaths so-called
nsdr very similar although different to
what's sometimes called Yoga Nidra which
is where you lie there you do a sort of
body scan some long exhale breathing and
SDR is very similar you can find a link
to a zero cost nsdr on YouTube it's a 10
minute long one there are also 20 and 30
minute ones out there also on YouTube
but I'll provide a link to the 10 minute
one
those have been shown to increase the
amount of dopamine in your dopamine
Reserves
by up to 65 percent which is a
remarkable number so quality sleep
non-sleep deep breast AKA Yoga Nidra
very powerful ways to keep your Baseline
level of dopamine at a sufficient level
in addition to that nutrition no doubt
plays a role in your Baseline level of
dopamine because tyrosine the amino acid
is the rate limiting enzyme For the
synthesis of dopamine
tyrosine is present in varying levels in
different foods you can look those up
online you just simply put in a search
for tyrosine levels in different foods
everything from particular cheeses like
parmesan cheese has high levels of
tyrosine certain meat certain nuts
certain vegetables without getting into
details in specifics you can find those
there but you need proper nutrition and
therefore nutrients in particular
tyrosine in order to have
sufficient levels of Baseline dopamine
the third thing on the list and again
these are things that we come back to
almost every episode but I don't think
they can be repeated enough because
these are really things that we need to
focus on every 24 hours you might be
able to skip a day here or there if you
get sick or you're traveling or you have
some major life event but really every
24 hours we need to re-up our sleep we
need to re-up our nutrients
even if you're fasting you're re-upping
your nutrients from stored sources
within your body
the third thing is sunlight morning
sunlight in particular I've done
extensive episodes about this check out
the episode on lighting your health if
you want all the details but you want to
try and view sunlight as early in the
day as possible
five to ten minutes on a clear day
minimum 10 to 20 minutes on a cloudy day
minimum
20 or 30 minutes on a very overcast day
minimum without sunglasses don't stare
at the sun please don't damage your eyes
look off slightly off from the Sun but
yes you want to face the Eastward
towards the Sun and on those cloudy days
that's especially important to do why
well viewing morning sunlight increases
cortisol early in the day which is
excellent because you want cortisol
elevated early in the day and you want
it lower later in the day and because of
the relationship between the cells in
your eye that sense sunlight
specifically morning sunlight believe it
or not that happens and signal to your
hypothalamus and the relationship
between the hypothalamus and the
pituitary and other endocrine organs
it sets in motion a dopamine-related
Cascade in
neuromodulators dopamine and hormones
that lead to states of well-being
elevated mood alertness Etc throughout
the day it also helps your sleep at
night but today we're talking about
dopamine so yes believe it or not that
morning sunlight exposure does increase
your levels of dopamine not just
cortisol
and fourth on the list is going to be
movement exercise of varying kinds be
resistance training could be
cardiovascular training that does
increase levels of dopamine here we're
not talking about achieving peaks in
dopamine right that could be
accomplished through setting a personal
record a PR or through Sprints or heavy
lifts or learning some new Dynamic
movement what we're really talking about
here is getting into a regular exercise
program of if not every day at least
five days a week a mixture of
cardiovascular and resistance exercise
that we also know is known to elevate
and maintain an elevated level of
Baseline dopamine so it's not just about
the Euphoria you feel during or after
exercise it's also about the Baseline
level of dopamine that's achieved
through regular movement and engaging in
movement and if you're asking how could
that be well you already know the answer
the circuits in the brain and body that
generate movement not just goal seeking
but movement itself as I mentioned
earlier that Niagara striatal pathway
and yes that circuit is separate from
the VTA nucleus accumbens to cortical
circuit the mesocortical circuit that
we've mainly been focusing on today but
they interact and so by engaging in
regular movement you ensure that you're
maintaining elevated levels of Baseline
dopamine which is what you want if
you're going to be able to engage in any
kind of motivated Pursuit behavior of
any kind so those are the fundamentals
that will set the level of Baseline
dopamine in your system
a couple of key points yes there is
variation based on both genetics and
Circumstance in Baseline levels of
dopamine if someone's going through a
particular hard time or if somebody
inherited a gene in the dopamine
synthesis pathway that simply affords
them higher levels of Baseline dopamine
we likely know these people they seem
hyper motivated all the time not just
based on prior success
but they just seem to have a lot of
energy and a lot of go drive you know
you talk about activation energy some of
you may know what that term means others
of you won't having low activation
energy is great I mean the amount of
energy that it takes to get into action
to pursue adaptive and meaningful
healthy goals some people just seem to
have lower activation energy and higher
levels of dopamine are probably
associated with that some of us have
lower levels of Baseline dopamine
regardless everyone needs to engage in
the foundational things that I just
mentioned a few moments ago every 24
hours or at least strive to there is no
escaping that I'd like to just take a
brief moment and thank one of our
podcast sponsors which is inside tracker
inside tracker is a personalized
nutrition platform that analyzes data
from your blood and DNA to help you
better understand your body and help you
reach your health goals I've long been a
believer in getting regular blood work
done for the simple reason that blood
work is the only way that you can
monitor the markers such as hormone
markers lipids metabolic factors Etc the
impact your immediate and long-term
health one major challenge with blood
work however is that most of the time it
does not come back with any information
about what to do in order to move the
values for hormones metabolic factors
lipids Etc into the ranges that you want
with inside tracker changing those
values becomes very straightforward
because it has a personalized dashboard
that you can use to address the
nutrition-based behavior-based
supplement-based approaches that you can
use in order to move those values into
the ranges that are optimal for you Your
vitality and your longevity inside
tracker now includes a measurement of
APO lipoprotein B so-called APO B in
their ultimate plan apob is a key marker
of cardiovascular health and therefore
there's extreme value to knowing your
apob levels if you'd like to try inside
tracker you can go to insidetracker.com
huberman to get 20 off any of inside
tracker's plans again that's inside
tracker.com huberman to get 20 off now
there are things that can increase one's
Baseline level of dopa being further
and some of those get us into the realm
of supplements and prescription drugs
but for now I just want to mention a few
of them that are purely behavioral in
nature are zero cost and that have been
shown in the research literature to
increase Baseline levels of dopamine for
long periods of time and this is
important because if any of you are out
there listening to this thing about
Peaks and troughs and bass lines you
might be asking wait what's the
difference between a Baseline and a peak
really because if for instance you get a
big peak well that's a peak in the
Baseline so how do you distinguish
between Peak and Baseline and well
there's a trough and let's say that
trough lasts an hour is that hour-long
trough for your baseline or you know
where's your set point how do you
establish your set point or more
importantly how do you raise your set
point ah well if you're not already
asking that question I just asked it for
you I Define an increase in your
Baseline level in dopamine to be
anything that increases dopamine for
more than one hour you know when we
think about cocaine and amphetamine
pornography sex caffeine things of that
sort regardless of how long one engages
in about of those behaviors or
substances
the increases in dopamine are going to
be relatively short-lived on the order
of minutes to an hour sometimes longer
now I didn't say that's how long you're
engaging in the behaviors I said that's
how long those increases in dopamine are
going to occur even if you were to
continually engage in those behaviors
and remember with continual engagement
in a dopamine spiking Behavior
a behavior that increases dopamine Peaks
the height of those Peaks remember gets
lower and lower and lower especially in
a short amount of time and then drops
below Baseline
there are tools and techniques that you
can use to elevate your Baseline level
of dopamine for long periods of time and
here again this is done in addition to
the basic tools that I mentioned a few
moments ago the simplest one for which
there are excellent data and here I'm
referring to data published in the
European Journal physiology I'll provide
a link to this is that
exposure of your body up to the neck to
cold water and it doesn't have to be
super cold by the way to cold water has
been shown to increase Baseline levels
of dopamine and the other so-called
catecholamines which include
norepinephrine and epinephrine but
for sake of today's discussion dopamine
in particular
for not just one but at least two and
probably as long as four or five hours
there have been some additional
scientific studies after the paper I
just mentioned
and it's really remarkable you can
accomplish this a number of different
ways you could get into a cold shower in
the morning and I do recommend doing
this in the morning and in that case
it's okay to get the water on your head
in fact I recommend it uh you could get
into an ice bath you could get into a
cold Plunge in these circumstances I'm
not suggesting this for sake of
increasing metabolism or fat loss and
the whole discussion around uh
deliberate cold and metabolism and fat
loss has become a little bit
controversial so we won't go there now
mostly because we're focused on the
clear ability of deliberate cold
exposure to increase dopamine for long
periods of time AKA your dopamine
Baseline
the ways to do this vary depending on
the temperature so for instance
there are data pointing to the fact that
if you want to get a long lasting
increase in your Baseline dopamine you
could take a very cold shower or cold
plunge or ice bath
for a very brief period of time anywhere
from 30 seconds to two minutes maybe
three minutes but probably 30 seconds to
two minutes now you might ask what is
very cold you have to be careful because
I don't want to recommend anything
that's going to cause anyone to have a
heart attack or go into shock or
anything of that sort
it's going to vary by person depending
on your level of cold tolerance what I
recommend is if you are going for the
short exposure long dopamine release
approach that is 30 seconds to two
minutes that you start warmer than you
think you need to and then you ease into
it over a few days
but we're really talking about ranges in
temperature from anywhere from about 37
degrees Fahrenheit to about 55 degrees
Fahrenheit again be careful approach it
with caution and ease into it I do
recommend doing this early in the day
and I should mention not after strength
or hypertrophy training because within
the six hours after strength or
hypertrophy training this deliberate
cold exposure especially immersion up to
the neck can suppress the strength and
hypertrophy adaptation that the training
is designed to accomplish okay so that's
one approach the other approach that's
supported by the literature to increase
Baseline levels of dopamine for very
long periods of time in fact this is the
original approach is to get into warmer
water so not warm but warmer so 60
degree Fahrenheit water
up to the neck and to stay there for
about 45 to 60 Minutes the reason I
don't think most people will do that or
that most people would prefer a shorter
colder exposure protocol is that most
people don't have 45 to 60 minutes each
morning to get into water and sit there
and in that study they actually had them
sitting in lawn chairs basically in the
shallow end of a pool up to their neck
for a full 60 minutes and then measuring
dopamine release and so forth so there
are a bunch of different ways to do this
I should emphasize I don't think you
need to be super precise about the
temperature and even the duration what I
recommend is
find a temperature that's uncomfortably
cold to you meaning that you feel
agitated you want to get out but that
you're confident you can safely stay in
and again I can't give a simple
prescriptive to everybody but this is
known to increase Baseline levels of
dopamine significantly in fact double
them or more for long periods of time
meaning hours up to four maybe even six
hours into the day which is one of the
reasons I suggest doing this early in
the day
I happen to get into a cold plunger take
a cold shower first thing in the morning
I do go outside and get my sunlight
first sometimes sometimes I do the cold
first it really depends on my
circumstances and how I'm feeling that
day I don't think it really matters
which one you do first but you want to
try and get both of those in early in
the day because you really want the
catecholamines and cortisol elevated
early in the day okay so that's
deliberate cold exposure we already
talked about exercise so if you're doing
your exercise early in the day there's
no reason why it couldn't be done in
concert with this deliberate cold
exposure I recommend doing the
deliberate cold exposure first for the
reasons we talked about a few minutes
ago and then of course there are
compounds both prescription and
over-the-counter compounds that can
indeed raise your Baseline levels of
dopamine for an hour or more and when I
say an hour or more it really depends on
individual variation in terms of how
quickly you metabolize dopamine and it
depends on individual variation in how
you manage or tolerate different dosages
of drugs and different types of drugs so
the typical drugs and here I'm talking
about legal
prescription drugs for increasing
dopamine are things like Ritalin
Adderall modafinil and arm modafinil
also tap into the system and I did an
entire episode about ADHD which is the
typical context in which you hear about
these prescription drugs but assuming
it's prescribed by a doctor for either
clinical reasons like ADHD or for other
reasons all of those compounds do
significantly increase Baseline levels
of dopamine for many many hours that's
absolutely clear and it's one of the
major reasons why those drugs are so
effective in increasing motivation and
attention then there are compounds that
are sold over the counter things like
amino acids such as l-tyrosine itself
that's a very commonly sold and used
amino acid it's present in a lot of
so-called pre-workout formulas I as many
of you know am a fan of single
ingredient supplements for the most part
aside from foundational supplements like
ag1 which give you many many
micronutrients kind of all together
because it would be nearly impossible to
consume each of those as individual
ingredients and get the right amounts
Etc but for all other supplements I'm a
big believer in parsing what you need
and what's most effective for you in
single ingredient formulations and the
typical ways in which people
work to elevate their Baseline levels of
dopamine
with supplements are using either
l-tyrosine which as I mentioned earlier
is the rate limiting enzyme for dopamine
or by using what's called mucuna purines
which is actually very similar to l-dopa
which is the treatment for Parkinson's
mechuna purines actually comes from the
velvety outside coating of a certain
bean I know it sounds really esoteric
but that's actually where it's found in
nature and it's really 99 l-dopa and I
confess having tried McCune appearance
having examined the scientific
literature on the cune appearance there
is some evidence that it can increase
dopamine especially in that
tuberinfrendibular pathway because it
can tap into some of the hormone-related
functions of the pituitary it does
increase alertness and mood it might
even increase libido motivation Etc but
the effects of mercuna purines tend to
be very much of the increasing the peak
in dopamine and then very quickly
dropping that peak in other words the
peak trough phenomenon not for
increasing Baseline levels of dopamine
now it's likely different for people
with Parkinson's who are taking
prescription drugs that are similar to
mercuna purine so if people have
Parkinson's oftentimes they are
prescribed things like l-dopa which is
in the pathway to dopamine synthesis or
they are prescribed things like
bromocriptine which will indeed increase
dopamine and I do realize that some
people use those prescription drugs
recreationally which I don't recommend
those drugs can be used to increase
Baseline levels of dopamine but more
typically they cause Peaks and dopamine
and troughs and dopamine which is why I
do not recommend them they are not going
to allow you to accomplish what you want
if your goal is more motivation Etc
in fact they are likely to do the
opposite give you a big peak an
alertness and then a crash that can
include depressive symptoms and just not
feeling very good
l-tyrosine however has been examined in
the scientific literature and at
reasonably low dosages has been shown to
increase circulating and available
levels of dopamine both in the brain and
body and lead to increased cognitive
performance and in some cases physical
output I'll provide links to a few of
these studies but the two that I really
parsed most finely for sake of this
episode really just focus on taking
l-tyrosine under conditions where your
Baseline levels of dopamine are reduced
due to stress and under conditions where
there's no stress and people are trying
to increase their Baseline levels of
dopamine for sake of improving cognitive
function the first paper is entitled
effective tyrosine on cognitive function
and blood pressure under stress I'll
provide a link to this in the show note
captions and it's one of many papers
really
dating back to the early 90s exploring
how
relatively High frankly relatively High
dosages of l-tyrosine Taken under
conditions of stress allow people to
rescue some of their cognitive function
in terms of working memory tasks and
other kind of cognitive tasks visual
Pursuit tasks and so on
the second paper is entitled tyrosine
improves working memory in a
multitasking environment and the second
paper is perhaps more interesting
because it involves exploring the use of
tyrosine supplementation basically
taking tyrosine about an hour before a
cognitive task or set of cognitive tasks
that involve a lot of multitasking and
working memory working memory for those
of you that don't know is your ability
to maintain small batches of information
in your mind for relatively short
periods of time so for instance if I
tell you my phone number or the phone
number where I grew up 493-2931
if you can remember that chances are
you'll remember it for 30 seconds 60
seconds but that you won't remember it
tomorrow because there's really no
reason to a lot of the tasks that we do
throughout the day involve working
memory and working memory is very
subject to interference from other tasks
that we happen to be doing like looking
at our phone or having a conversation or
trying to navigate through a city
it involves a lot of attention and this
study shows that tyrosine improves
working memory especially in the context
of multitasking and having a lot of
conflicting goals and they did a number
of really nice experiments here it's
again it's a small study not that many
subjects but it's one of several papers
in fact this is the paper that kind of
set in motion the Domino of other papers
exploring the efficacy of l-tyrosine for
cognitive performance and they looked at
working memory tasks of course but also
auditory visual tasks and they involve
some interference of visual cues and
things of that sort and they saw some
really interesting effects basically
when we need to attend to multiple
things at the same time l-tyrosine can
help us do that at least as it relates
to memory when I say althyrosine what I
really mean is having your Baseline
levels of dopamine elevated can really
help navigate multitasking environments
especially as it relates to working
memory and this is true under conditions
of stress and under conditions of not
stressful okay you might say well isn't
multitasking stressful itself yes it can
be but when we talk about under
conditions of stress we're talking about
people who are sleep deprived we're
talking about people that are under
other kinds of psychological or physical
stress l-tyrosine can help in that
context as well so as I mentioned before
in these studies they use very high
dosages of l-tyrosine so high that
actually I don't recommend them they did
measure stress hormones they did measure
blood pressure and things of that sort
but I want to caution you I do not
recommend I will say it again I do not
recommend following the dosages that
were used in these two studies
because they are exceedingly high they
used 100 milligrams per kilogram of body
weight of tyrosine one hour prior to
these cognitive tasks now I weigh about
220 pounds I'm a little bit lighter than
that so that's a hundred kilograms
approximately
translated from this study that would
mean that had I participated in the
study and I wasn't in the placebo group
but I was in the l-tyrosine group I
would have been given 10 000 milligrams
of l-tyrosine which is 10 grams of
l-tyrosine I do not recommend that in
fact there are papers showing that as
little as 500 milligrams
but perhaps up to one gram that is a
thousand milligrams or 1500 milligrams a
gram and a half of l-tyrosine Taken 30
to 60 minutes before a cognitive or
physical task can increase Baseline
levels of dopamine for extended periods
of time and thereby improve performance
on those mental or physical tasks
so
if you are somebody who's interested in
trying l-tyrosine please know that the
increases in Baseline levels of dopamine
can be substantial they are long lasting
which qualifies them as Baseline
increases as opposed to Peaks and I
would say you should also start with the
lowest possible dose so for most people
250 to 500 milligrams is going to be a
reasonable starting dose depending on
your body weight smaller people start
with 250 larger maybe 500 keep an eye on
whether or not you're combining it with
caffeine or with any other stimulants
and keep in mind that again the bigger
the peak in dopamine the bigger the
trough in dopamine afterwards so pay
attention to whether or not you
experience a crash that same day or the
next day but chances are if you're using
a relatively low level of l-tyrosine so
anywhere from 250 maybe 500 milligrams
or a thousand milligrams of l-tyrosine
prior to cognitive or physical work and
taken early in the day by the way
because this can act as a bit of a
stimulant that you're going to achieve
these long lasting increases in Baseline
dopamine but please also keep in mind
that that I always always suggest that
you engage in the proper behaviors and
you disengage from the improper
behaviors as a first line of offense on
any health goal so now you know how to
set your Baseline levels of dopamine at
the highest possible level
you of course want to guard that
Baseline level of dopamine very
carefully so for instance you want to
avoid any kind of behaviors or
substances that are going to Peak your
Baseline level of dopamine very high or
very sharply or if you do engage in
those types of behaviors whatever they
may be that you are well aware that your
Baseline level of dopamine will drop far
below what it was after that Peak has
fallen you will be essentially in the
quote unquote trough
if however you find yourself in that
trough you now have the knowledge to
understand that that trough will resolve
if you wait enough time that Baseline
level of dopamine that you were at prior
to the peak will come back you will feel
better however most people don't know
that and as a consequence when they feel
that low
that is they feel kind of a motivated
maybe a little bit depressed maybe a lot
ammotivated or a lot depressed following
some quote unquote Peak experience
what they end up doing is thinking about
what caused that Peak experience and
then go back and try to re-engage in the
behavior and try and regenerate that
Peak experience but you now know that
that is a terrible strategy in fact that
strategy will only lead to diminished
Peaks from the same experience it will
lead to in many cases pursuing more and
more intense experiences to try and
recapitulate recreate that big peak
which won't work or even worse people
start stacking and combining different
dopamine increasing behaviors in order
to try and obtain something like that
initial Peak when in fact all they need
to do all you need to do is simply wait
because the way that the dopamine
circuitry is arranged is that it's not
just about pleasure as you know it's
about motivation desire Pursuit and
pleasure and it also has everything to
do with pain and discomfort
now when people hear the word pain they
often think oh pain okay so a physical
pain or an intense emotional pain but
today we're going to talk about pain a
little bit differently we're going to
talk about the pain associated with the
trough and dopamine that occurs after a
big peak in dopamine
as a period in which
pain and effort go hand in hand and I'll
return to this in a moment but I want
you to just note that in your mind kind
of earmark that in your mind because
what we're about to talk about is how to
leverage that pain and to use effort as
a way to not just get out of the trough
more quickly but actually to get back to
a higher level of Baseline as you exit
that trough meanwhile I really want to
harp on this one point that I made a
moment ago which is that after some big
experience so it could be a vacation or
a night out partying or the birth of a
new child all of these are well-known
phenomena that lead to troughs or
deficits in dopamine afterwards which
can cause a sort of postpartum
depression postpartum depression is a
phrase normally used to describe
literally postpartum post-birth of a
child depression and that has many
causes not just related to dopamine
baselines although it does involve
dopamine baselines but it has hormonal
aspects and other aspects as well but
postpartum depression is also used to
describe any time that our Baseline
dopamine has has gone down way way below
what it was prior to some recent Peak or
exciting exhilarating win or behavior
couple of things that one can do in
order to get out of that trough more
quickly the first one is simply to wait
with the understanding that you will get
out I know that sounds overly simplistic
and maybe a little bit brutal but I
think most people don't realize this
they don't realize that the dopamine
circuitry does take time to replenish
and it has everything to do with
restoring both the synthesis of dopamine
as well as What's called the readily
releasable pool of dopamine so dopamine
is packaged in these little spherical
things that we call vesicles those
vesicles are released from the ends of
nerves so in this case we're talking
about the nerves that originate again
and
VTA and nucleus accumbens and send their
little wires up to the prefrontal cortex
and that's where dopamine is released
and that readily releasable pool of
dopamine takes time to replenish and
that can take several days in order to
replenish just knowing that can help you
through that process and of course then
it raises the question is there anything
that you can do to accelerate that
process and indeed there is and indeed
this is what I consider not just
something to get you out of a trench of
kind of lower mood and motivation but
actually what represents the Holy Grail
of motivation today I'm going to talk
about this pain effort process as a very
powerful way to get out of sticking
points but more importantly to get into
a mode where effort and reward can
actually accelerate your progress along
any path to any goal and in a way that
you can do it repeatedly and this is not
simply taking mechanisms from biology
and painting names on them rather this
is leveraging mechanisms in biology that
are well defined in the animal and human
in literature that have parallels to the
addiction and addiction recovery
literature but that have been shown in
specific circumstances to really allow
people to engage in motivational
Pursuits in a variety of context School
relationships work etc in an ongoing way
and in a way that never depletes their
Baseline of dopamine to the point where
they have to do a lot of extra work to
get it back and in a way that allows
them to be really motivated in a variety
of contexts in an Adaptive way so what
we're really talking about here is
regardless of your genetics regardless
of who your parents are which obviously
you couldn't select
being able to leverage your dopamine
system in order to be maximally
motivated when you want to be and indeed
to avoid procrastination I'd like to
tell you about a classic experiment that
I've described once before on this
podcast but frankly this experiment is
so crucial I don't think it can be
described enough
this was an experiment that was done at
Stanford many years ago and involved
children but it's actually been repeated
in adults
the experiment involved observing a
classroom of young children so these
were kids about kindergarten age a
little bit older and observing which
activities kids like to do in their free
time so their structured time where they
had to you know these are little kids so
they play blocks or they had to
um sing or they had to write or or do
what they could or I suppose draw
they're probably not writing um
significant prose at that age but then
they had free time where they could do
whatever they wanted and what the
researchers did was observe the children
who selected by their own choice to draw
pictures so there were some tables out
with crayons and markers and paper Etc
and there were some kids that would just
naturally go to that activity every day
because they liked that activity
and they measured how much of the free
time these children elected to use their
free time drawing doing these different
art projects
and then what they did was they started
introducing rewards to these children
they started putting a gold star or in
some cases a silver star on their pieces
of artwork and telling them what a good
job they did and the kids really liked
that in fact who wouldn't right they're
not only doing an activity that they
like but they're also getting a reward
for it so you can probably see where
this is all going what they were doing
was they were increasing the amount of
dopamine that these children experience
and again in parallel experiments done
with adults if you take adults who enjoy
a particular activity you let them do
activity and then you start rewarding
them for that activity especially when
you surprise them with a reward for an
activity they already like
they report that being a much more
pleasurable experience than had they
just done the activity
then what they did with these children
and in the experiments with adults done
later on was they cease giving them the
reward and then they observe what
percentage of their free time they spend
doing that activity drawing and what
they observed was you guessed it a drop
in the total amount of time that the
children elected to do this activity
that initially they were doing quite a
lot in other words
their total satisfaction or desire or
motivation to engage in this activity
drop below what it was prior to ever
receiving a reward and again this has
been repeated in a variety of contexts
in different populations different
cultures different countries men women
boys girls lots of different backgrounds
so what this tells us is everything you
already know which is that reward
prediction error is not just about the
desire to do something and you carrying
it out and it being pretty good
amazing or not good okay I always like
to joke that the nervous system sort of
codes things into three bins you can
think about this in terms of food or any
type of experience it can either be yum
yes I really like that yuck I really
don't like that or meh it's kind of so
so
what the scenario led to where rewards
were received for an activity that
people already like to do and then
removed was that an activity that at one
point was a yum becomes a meh and that
all reflects a drop in Baseline dopamine
why because the activity that the
children or adults liked combined with
the gold star or the monetary reward or
praise that children and adults seem to
like compounded to create a bigger peak
in dopamine and therefore a bigger
trough in dopamine and if you're already
wondering whether or not their desire to
engage in that activity eventually came
back it did indeed so essentially what I
described all matches precisely with
dopamine reward prediction error and the
fact that peaks in dopamine give rise to
subsequent troughs and dopamine that if
one Waits long enough
allow Baseline levels of dopamine to
return to normal
and of course the amplitude of that
dopamine Peak has been varied by giving
more money or less money in different
scenarios nearly all the different
derivations of the experiments that you
could imagine that map onto the Dynamics
of dopamine release that we've been
talking about during this episode all
played out exactly as one would have
predicted based on the neural circuitry
and the Dynamics of dopamine I recommend
that you leverage this knowledge to make
sure that any activities that you enjoy
to do whether or not you enjoyed a
little or a lot but especially if you
enjoy it a lot that you guard and
Protect by making sure that you don't
start layering in or attaching reward or
other sources of dopamine releasing
behaviors or substances to that specific
behavior or if you do that you don't do
it terribly often now how often is
terribly often we'll get to that in a
moment but let me give you an example
from my life just as an example but you
will likely have and you'll know people
that will have different examples
I love to exercise I know to some people
uh this might seem foreign but I love to
exercise I love to do resistance
training I love to run I am not one of
those people that doesn't like the
experience of exercising but likes the
feeling afterwards quote unquote I hear
that a lot I don't like to exercise but
I love the way I feel afterwards I love
physical training and I love the way I
feel afterwards but I mostly love the
feeling during I don't know why I'm
wired that way I can't say that I'm
somebody who likes to do hard things
across the board there are plenty of
difficult things in life that I dread or
that I'm sort of meh about
but for me hard exercise intense
exercise of a particular kind resistance
training and running in particular
both give me a yum yes I love this kind
of feeling and yes it persists for me
quite a long while afterwards both for
sake of the way that it changes my
neurochemistry but also my sense of
satisfaction but I just simply love it
now years ago I discovered that if I
drink
a cup of black coffee or an Americano or
a double espresso or some yerba mate
that my workouts can be quite a bit more
intense I can run further and then I
also discovered that if I were to take a
pre-workout energy drink or I took say
300 milligrams of alpha GPC and 500
milligrams of phenylethylamine and
perhaps even 500 milligrams of
l-tyrosine and perhaps did that
alongside the caffeine in the Yerba mate
then yes absolutely I really like those
workouts I could be like a laser in
terms of focus I could exert even more
effort put on some music and I could
achieve even better performance and then
I also discovered that I could
export that protocol of caffeine yerba
mate and various supplements to my
cognitive work so I was when I was
studying or writing papers or writing
grants or in the laboratory when I was
doing experiments with my hands in those
days you know cutting brain tissue and
staining it and working really long
hours and I discovered that all of those
things all of those behaviors compounded
with my love of exercise and my love of
doing science and gave me these big
peaks in what to me felt like even
important experiences they felt you know
unlike anything else they were just so
so peak in their nature
which was great and it did indeed
enhance my performance however
while it did not create a dependency for
those different substances caffeine
supplements Etc what I noticed was that
in the days and sometimes weekends
afterwards even though for much of my
career I confess I've worked weekends as
well but I would notice that I'd
experience a real trough in energy I
just would not feel that good and then
if I kept up those behaviors
consistently and I was consistently
adding in these other let's just call
them what they are dopamine releasing or
stimulating behaviors and substances
that my enthusiasm for physical training
or running
or for doing experiments actually
started to diminish and this was really
discouraging to me at the time because I
started to think okay maybe I'm burnt
out maybe I have adrenal burnout which
by the way doesn't exist folks your
adrenals don't burn out there is
something called adrenal insufficiency
syndrome you can over stimulate your
system by way of too much adrenaline
epinephrine and norepinephrine but
that's a separate thing there's no such
thing as adrenal burnout per se
but I didn't know that so I thought gosh
I'm really burnt out when in fact
it's now obvious to me what I was doing
I was combining too many dopamine
releasing or stimulating behaviors in
substances for things that I already
enjoyed doing as behaviors namely
exercise and doing experiments anything
related to science actually
so what this means is not to avoid
taking things or doing things that
amplify your amount of dopamine but to
be very cautious about how often one
does that and how many different
dopamine stimulating behaviors or
compounds one stacks
especially in terms of taking those
things or stacking those things
in and around behaviors that you already
really enjoy doing I was essentially
just creating another version of the
kids in nursery school or first grade
with the gold star experiment I was
basically just doing the exact same
thing and when I realized that and I
changed my relationship to those
compounds I didn't eliminate them all
together but I started realizing for
instance that I didn't need to double up
on yerba mate and coffee every workout
sometimes I would do one sometimes I
would do the other frankly I always do
one or the other it's rare that I ever
do any kind of physical training without
some caffeine first and I do my physical
training typically in the early part of
the day so that's fine doesn't interfere
with my sleep
I might do a hike without caffeine but
if I'm in a weight trainer I'm going to
run I tend to drink coffee beforehand or
have yerba mate
or if I occasionally meaning about once
every third sometimes every other but
usually about every third workout I'll
take 300 milligrams of alpha GPC maybe
occasionally maybe every third or fourth
workout and these are resistance
workouts mind you not running I'll take
500 milligrams of l-tyrosine or more
typically 500 milligrams of phenol
ethylamine and very very rarely maybe
once every two or three months I might
stack all of those things together prior
to a workout but of course I'm always
mindful to also include workouts or runs
or bouts of cognitive work so that could
be grant writing prepping for a podcast
Etc where I don't do anything prior
maybe just my caffeine because I have a
baseline level of caffeine that I use
each day to function like many people
there's a baseline level of caffeine
that just allows us to function if we're
a Perpetual user of caffeine I talked a
lot about this on the episode in
caffeine but the key here is be cautious
I would say be very cautious about
stacking and layering in too many
dopamine Peak inducing behaviors all at
once on a regular basis the key Point
here is if you are somebody that can
engage in these intrinsically joyful
activities for you these activities that
you're really motivated to do whether or
not it's skiing or playing music or
dancing Etc without the need to layer in
additional dopamine releasing mechanisms
or compounds or activities well then I
highly recommend you do that because
then you are essentially making yourself
one of those fortunate few that does not
require additional stimuli and therefore
can hold on to that pleasure can hold on
to that intrinsic pleasure and
motivation to engage in these behaviors
over time which frankly there is no
replacement for there is no pill or
bottle or potion or motivational speech
or podcast or book that can replace
intrinsic motivation intrinsic
motivation is perhaps the Holy Grail of
all human Endeavors and behaviors
because it encompasses so much of what
brought us to this point in our species
Evolution and also what brings each and
every one of us closer and closer to our
goals and if it's happening with
enjoyment without the need to layer in
additional tools well then you have
really tapped into the source and when I
say the source I don't mean it in any
kind of mystical way I think it's quite
clear by now that when we hear about Chi
from Eastern medicine or we talk about
motivation drive and pursuit in on
Western neurobiological languages that
relates to dopamine or we hear about the
source maybe in my podcast episode with
the one and only Rick Rubin incredibly
productive music producer who's as an
just an unbelievable track record
in terms of creative Endeavors and he
talks about the source we're really
talking about the same thing which is
this set of circuits within us that
allow us to identify what we want and
then lean into effort and then to do
that in a persistent way that allows us
to reach our goals and if we can do that
with an intrinsic sense of pleasure well
that is nothing short of magic but of
course it's not magic it's science and
of course most people are not concerned
about trying to protect the things they
already enjoy in order to make sure that
they can continue to do those things and
enjoy them most people are thinking
about how they can engage and pursue
things that are less than pleasureful to
them or how they can continue to engage
in motivated behaviors when the going
gets tough or and this is a big one I
hear this over and over again as a
request to cover on this podcast how
people can overcome procrastination what
we're going to talk about now is how the
Dynamics of dopamine release that you
already are aware of plus and additional
Dynamic that we haven't quite talked
about can allow you to leverage dopamine
in a way that really will bring you to
the Holy Grail of motivation and drive
which is
when effort starts to become the reward
itself in other words when friction
becomes the reward I know that sounds
crazy to some of you but when friction
becomes the reward you can pass from an
idea and a goal no matter how daunting
to successful completion of that goal
while experiencing what essentially will
feel like pleasure the entire time now
that doesn't mean it will be Bliss the
entire time but what is very possible is
to leverage the Dynamics of both
dopamine Peaks and dopamine troughs
in order to not just maintain your
Baseline level of dopamine but to also
pull yourself out of any kind of
procrastination or other kind of
overthinking trenches very quickly and
get back into a mode of pursuit so how
do we make effort the reward you may
have heard about this in the context of
so-called growth mindset growth mindset
is the incredible Discovery and research
papers from my colleague Dr Carol dweck
in the psychology department at Stanford
and there are others such as David
Yeager at the University of Texas Austin
who have leveraged the so-called growth
mindset as a tool that young people and
adults alike can use in order to get
better at anything and the basic Contour
of growth mindset is to adopt the
mindset that if you can't do something
or if you can't do it well
that you can't do it or can't do it well
yet it's that word yet that's really key
and there are a number of different
tools and techniques that people use to
adopt growth mindset but it all starts
with that relationship to not being able
to do it yet now that all sounds pretty
straightforward when you tell yourself
but when we are in a performance context
when we expect ourselves to be able to
motivate or when we expect ourselves to
be able to perform and we can't that
often sets up a downward spiral of
motivation because we are so used to
being attached to the relationship
between
desire motivation and outcomes reward
prediction error we want something we
want that a in class or we want to learn
how to dance or we want to be able to do
this uh physical skill of another kind
or learn a language or get the mate we
desire or make the relationship work or
make the business work on and on and
then we get the outcome that we don't
want and our confidence for lack of a
better word drops over time oftentimes
that leads to situations where we are
not motivated we are a motivated it can
even lead to situations where we are
downright depressed
there's also circumstances where people
myself included of course procrastinate
we know we should do something but
somehow we can't get motivated we know
that if we put in the effort we'll get
there but we can't do it either because
we don't like the activity or we're just
not feeling great now we could
be quote unquote not feeling great not
feeling motivated because our dopamine
Baseline is low and so I absolutely
encourage everybody to take a look at
themselves anytime they're in a
motivated State take a look at the
landscape of their life not just at that
moment but in the preceding days and
weeks and ask whether or not you've been
tending to those foundational things we
talked about earlier whether or not you
are engaging any other of the tools that
we talked about earlier to see if you
can get into a motivated State however
if all of those boxes are checked you
answer yes I'm doing all those things
I'm just not motivator I'm just whatever
reason I just procrastinating I don't
know I don't want to do it or I'm not
feeling motivated
well then there's a very potent set of
tools that you can leverage to overcome
states of lack of motivation overcome
procrastination and indeed can help you
deal with things like overthinking as it
relates to procrastination and lack of
motivation as well so the way this works
is the following
if you recall
a peak in dopamine is followed by a
trough in dopamine that trough in
dopamine is experienced as pain or
wanting or craving that pain that I'm
referring to is actually a craving or a
wanting
and it's a craving you're wanting for a
specific state that you would like to
achieve that is different than the one
that you're in you want to get out of
that trough and as you recall from
earlier in the episode that trough is
the stimulus for the ongoing release of
dopamine that provides the propeller the
motivation to go forward and seek some
goal okay so when we are not motivated
when we are in a so-called a-motivated
state
or when we are procrastinating or when
we just sort of can't seem to get in
gear the key to getting out of that pain
trough is one of two things I already
told you earlier you can just wait you
can wait till your motivation comes back
and a lot of people do wait in fact they
procrastinate they start doing other
things that are less painful than the
state that they happen to be in
when they are you know trying to get
into gear to go work out because I
realize not everyone wants to do that or
to study or to have a hard conversations
whatever it is
and what do they do they start engaging
in activities that we and indeed they
would not consider pleasureful
activities they start for instance
cleaning the house so seemingly out of
nowhere they start engaging in these
activities that normally are not
intrinsically pleasureful for them
they're not highly motivated to do them
as a replacement for doing the very
thing that they quote unquote need to do
or ought to do and that they're
procrastinating to do
what they're essentially doing here is a
mild type of addiction replacement in
other words rather than be in the
painful State and wait for it to pass
they're doing things that give them some
sense of accomplishment ostensibly
to give them the sense that they're
completing things and perhaps and I
don't know because I'm not um in the
psychology of knowing what other people
are thinking
perhaps in order to generate the
momentum in order to get engaged enough
or motivated enough to study or work out
or whatever activity it is that they're
trying to avoid through procrastination
now what's interesting about this
Dynamic is first of all it's extremely
common
and second of all a lot of people will
use this as a tactic so that they get
very close to the deadline to complete
something and then they go into a sort
of pseudo panic and then use anxiety as
a way to leverage their mental and
physical resources to complete that
thing how do I know the Contour of this
so well how do I understand the inner
dynamics of it well part of that relates
to my work as a neurobiologist and
reading the papers that I'll mention to
you in a moment but it also relates to
the fact that I'm somebody who Waits
quite a while right up until the sort of
last minute possible to complete
something for activities that I don't
want to do something I've been working
on my whole life in any case I'm very
familiar with the procrastination
process
so how can we overcome procrastination
well it turns out that there are
findings from within the addiction
literature that turn out to be very
powerful towards leveraging our way out
of procrastination and it has to do with
this
you already know because I've told you
probably a dozen times now that the
depth of the trough after a dopamine
Peak is proportional to how high that
Peak was and how steep it was how
quickly that Peak occurred it turns out
that not only is the depth of the trough
proportional to that but the rate at
which you get out of that trough
is proportional to how steep that trough
is
let me explain this for you in as clear
terms as I possibly can imagine you're
in an a-motivated State you're just not
feeling motivated you're procrastinating
you may think okay the thing to do here
is something I'll clean the house I'll
take care of some bills I'll do
something or I'll just wait those
approaches as we talked about before
generally don't work or at least don't
work quickly or they lead you right up
to the deadline and that's the deadline
that forces you to get something done or
you just don't get it done and you don't
succeed in your goal that happens a lot
as well
however if you were to take that state
of being unmotivated or procrastinating
and actually do something that's harder
than being in that a-motivated state
in other words doing something that's
more effortful even painful
you can rebound yourself out of that
dopamine trough much more quickly so
what do I mean you want to put yourself
in a state that's worse than or harder
than the state that you're in or do
something quote unquote more painful and
here I want to be very clear I'll say
this three times but I'm going to say it
for the first time now when I say more
painful I do not mean doing any kind of
tissue damaging or psychologically
damaging Behavior or anything of that
sort that's going to render you injured
or not well even in the short term
that's not what I'm referring to okay
let's just get that one out of the way
what I'm referring to
is the fact that for instance if you're
feeling a motivated but you find
yourself cleaning the house as a way to
procrastinate you can say well cleaning
the house is harder than sitting down
and doing nothing but actually in that
moment or in those moments that's not
the case or else you wouldn't be doing
it the reality is that the dopamine
system works according to what feels
hard or easy in the Moment In other
words if you're feeling a motivated you
need to do something and put yourself
into a state that's harder than the
state you're in so for instance if
you're sitting around feeling a
motivated or you find yourself tending
to tasks that are irrelevant to the goal
that you really should be focused on
you need to put your body and mind into
a state of discomfort
quickly and the way to do that is to
either engage in some tangential
activity meaning an activity not related
to your goal that puts your body into a
very different state so here again I'll
default to the obvious one which is
something like cold shower or cold
immersion which not only increases
dopamine long term or over several hours
rather but for most people is
experienced as pain that pain causes a
rebound out of that dopamine trough
faster than it would occur if you had
just stayed in that a motivated State
and waited for it to go away or done
something like cleaning up that for
whatever reason felt like it required
less friction when I say friction I mean
limbic friction your limbic system is
always in this dialogue with your
forebrain and limbic friction goes two
ways limbic friction can be you're tired
and you don't want to do something
and so you have to quote unquote
motivate to do it energize yourself to
do it or limbic friction can be that
you're nervous and scared and anxious to
do something and you have to calm
yourself in order to lean forward into
action in order to do that thing despite
the anxiety I realize this can be a
little bit confusing as a concept so I
want to go into a bit more detail let's
imagine that you or somebody else does
not like to exercise you don't want
exercise and you're trying to get your
minimum of five days per week exercise
and you're just not motivated to do it
there are a couple different techniques
to doing this assuming you've taken care
of all the Baseline stuff all the
foundational stuff we talked about
earlier and you're just not getting in
gear and you find yourself you know
checking your phone or maybe you're
tending into some tasks obviously those
things are quote unquote easier for you
meaning they cause less limbic friction
than engaging in exercise
the typical advice would be
just exercise for one minute okay just
get one minute of exercise or five
minutes and then use the successful
completion of that one or five minutes
as a milestone that allows you to then
move to the next Milestone and indeed
that approach can work and it's exactly
what I'm describing here when I say that
you're in a state of lack of motivation
or procrastination or both and you need
to put yourself into a more painful not
less painful state so what do you do you
push up against that friction and you
exercise for a short while and then that
pops you out of that trough that's
possible but for a lot of people even
that won't be possible because they just
can't get motivated or they do that one
minute or five minutes and they're just
like okay I'm still in the trough I'm
not actually feeling that great
in those circumstances it makes sense to
do something that's tangential to the
whole path that you're trying to pursue
this goal that you're trying to pursue
that is Believe It or Not much worse
than just being a motivated and when I
say worse I don't mean picking some task
that normally you don't like to do but
now you're willing to do I mean
literally thinking about what would be
worse than being in this state again
without causing yourself tissue or
psychological damage what would be worse
well cold water would be worse for many
people very cold water so the key is to
figure out something that for lack of a
better way to put it really sucks really
sucks and yet is safe and by doing that
you steepen
the trough you steepen the slope of the
trough which we know brings you back to
your Baseline level of dopamine more
quickly now for some people that will be
deliberate cold exposure through cold
shower ice bath and I have to tell you
that if you're cringing as I say this
well then there you go you now have a
tool that you know you cringe even when
you just think about and therefore
represents a great tool for you so if
I'm procrastinating to do something I
really need to do should I just simply
wait for that procrastination to
evaporate no will it eventually
evaporate maybe will a deadline
eventually surface that will trigger me
into an anxious or activated state that
will allow me to complete what needs to
be done maybe
hopefully
but better would be to get out of that a
motivated state that state of
procrastination quickly and to do so you
need to leverage something that's
painful so for instance I heard a
beautiful lecture recently done by Dr
Anna Lemke at Stanford School of
Medicine discussing dopamine and some of
the things in her book and some newer
findings as well and somebody in the
audience asked her the question does
meditation increase dopamine now earlier
we talked about how non-sleep deep rest
In Yoga Nidra has been shown in the
scientific literature to increase
dopamine but I also mentioned earlier
that classic forms of meditation whether
eyes open or eyes closed so-called open
monitoring or closed monitoring
meditation sitting there lying there and
focusing does not increase dopamine
levels per se however for most people
especially people who find it hard to
meditate or who don't do that practice
very often
meditation is effortful getting into
meditation and staying in meditation is
effortful
so if you find yourself in a state of
procrastination oftentimes a brief five
to ten minute meditation where you
absolutely do not allow yourself to do
anything besides close your eyes focus
on your breath and when your mind drifts
get back to your breath is not only
extremely difficult and extremely
frustrating unless you're a
well-practiced meditator but it's often
difficult and frustrating not just to do
but to get into that practice and not
just to get into that practice but to
maintain that practice for that mere
five to ten minutes because it's just
not a natural state for us to be in we
have to force ourselves so it is
effortful in fact it qualifies as a
basically available almost anywhere
anytime type of effortful activity that
if you dislike it perhaps even as much
as some people dislike deliberate cold
exposure well then perfect you now have
an additional tool in your kit that you
can use anytime you are feeling a
motivated and procrastinating
now there are numerous examples I could
give and hopefully there are numerous
examples that you're thinking about the
key is to have a short list of about
five different effortful AKA painful
activities that you can employ anytime
you're feeling a motivated or in a state
of procrastination keeping in mind that
the goal is not what you accomplish
inside of that activity although it is
important that you actually engage in
that activity I actually have to make
myself meditate in that five to ten
minute little bout of effortful or
painful activity but it's not about
achieving an outcome it's about forcing
your body and mind into a deeper state
of pain and discomfort in other words
taking yourself from that trough that
you're already in and steepening and
deepening that trough because in
steepening and deepening that trough we
know that the return from that trough to
normal and even elevated levels of
Baseline dopamine is going to be faster
and more robust and in doing that you
will quick quickly find yourself back
into a motivated State because not only
does it teach you that doing hard things
is possible that's sort of more of a
subjective cognitive learning but it
actually Taps into the very
neurochemical system that allows you to
then feel motivated and capable to
pursue the larger goal which is the
thing you're really concerned about
after all so as is often the case
perhaps always the case on this podcast
we covered a lot of material we cover
dopamine and what it is we talked about
the circuitry and the different kinds of
circuitry focusing mainly on this
mesocortical pathway that is so vitally
important to motivation for any goals
talked about the relationship between
Peaks and troughs and bass lines and the
foundational tools that allow us to set
and maintain a healthy Baseline level of
dopamine as well as ways to protect that
Baseline level of dopamine and we talked
about how to get ourselves out of states
of procrastination
and a Motivation by not just waiting out
those troughs in dopamine but actually
making those troughs and dopamine
steeper by engaging in things that are
effortful and things that we really
don't want to do in those moments
provided that those things are safe we
can get out of those dopamine troughs
more quickly and back to our dopamine
baseline or even above Baseline and we
talked about what I really view as the
Holy Grail of motivation which is to be
able to learn to attach reward to the
effort process itself and to do so by
not just understanding but also learning
to subjectively recognize and
somatically experience release of these
different stressful chemicals within our
body I realized this was a lot of
information and yet throughout I've
tried to highlight tools that you can
use that range from behavioral to
nutritional supplementation tools
cognitive tools and keep in mind that
all of these different segments of the
podcast is always are time stamps so if
you feel the need to go back and listen
to any of these in order to get clearer
understanding we've made that easy to do
so so simply look for the time stamps in
the show note captions if you're
learning from and or enjoying this
podcast please subscribe to our YouTube
channel that's a terrific zero cost way
to support us in addition please
subscribe to the podcast on Apple and
Spotify and on both apple and Spotify
you can leave us up to a five-star
review if you have questions for me or
comments about the podcast or
suggestions about topics you'd like me
to cover or guess you'd like me to
interview on The huberman Lab podcast
please put those in the comments section
on YouTube I do read all the comments in
addition please check out the sponsors
mentioned at the beginning and
throughout today's episode that's the
best way to support this podcast during
today's podcast and on many previous
episodes of The uberman Lab podcast we
discuss supplements while supplements
aren't necessary for everybody many
people derive tremendous benefit from
them for things like enhancing sleep
hormone support focus and many other
aspects of mental health physical health
and performance the huberman Lab podcast
is happy to announce that we partnered
with momentous supplements if you'd like
to learn more about the supplements
mentioned on today's and other episodes
of The huberman Lab podcast go to live
momentous spelled ous so
livemomentis.com huberman if you haven't
already signed up for the huberman Lab
podcast neural network newsletter it's a
monthly newsletter that provides
summaries of podcast episodes and Tool
kits toolkits are summaries and links to
specific protocols that you can use that
have been discussed on various podcast
episodes so we have a toolkit for sleep
for neuroplasticity for deliberate cold
exposure and much much more to sign up
for the newsletter which by the way is
completely zero cost go to
hubermanlab.com
go to the menu scroll down to newsletter
and provide your email we do not share
your email with anybody thank you once
again for joining me for today's Deep
dive discussion into dopamine and its
practical applications and last but
certainly not least thank you for your
interest in science
[Music]